What again,
another podcast,
ladies and gentlemen,
what more could they possibly have to say?
Have they not run out of shit to say,
right?
We kind of have a little bit.
Yeah.
I feel like I'd have to go out a lot and do stupid shit.
Just still have stories,
but then I can't tell the stories because then it will get me in trouble.
Yeah.
I feel like,
well,
I'm the exact opposite.
I feel like I need to stay home.
Read Shit.
You're out there trying to fuck up your life with the super aids.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com right now.
We're waiting for,
uh,
for Rick Ross,
the not rapper Rick Ross,
the real Rick Ross.
And,
uh,
he's,
I think he's caught up in some core thing.
Is it because of the Rick Ross thing that he's in court?
Because the rapper thing,
some other shit and,
uh,
he's on his way over here.
So when he gets over here,
we're going to have him on.
But for now it's just me and Brian keeping it sexy.
Go to on a.com use the code Dean Brogan,
save 10% off any and all supplements.
Um,
I,
I've done this commercial so long,
so many times,
there's no way to do it any differently.
Uh,
but if you've never heard it before on it is uh,
essentially,
uh,
I want to call it like a performance company is,
didn't somebody say that?
That's a good,
uh,
way to describe it.
It's essentially a company based on selling you all the best health,
wellness and fitness supplements available.
The Best Shit we can find and sell it to you at a very reasonable rate and sell
it to you in a way we're not,
we're not trying to rip anybody off.
We want to make sure that people who try these products know that the only
reason why we're selling them is because we use them ourselves.
It's the best shit that's available.
We have a 100% money back,
money back guarantee on your first order of 30 pills for the first 90 days.
You just say you don't even have to return the product just so you don't like
it.
Say it sucks.
And you get your money back.
No one is trying to rip you off.
The stuff that we're selling you is the best.
Like as far as like performance and physical performance.
This quarter [inaudible] mushroom supplement,
it's called shroom tech sport and it's amazing,
one of the best supplements I've ever used for like energy and for workouts for
intense workouts.
Um,
Alpha brain is the best,
best common combination of cognitive enhancing supplements we could find.
And that's what we did.
We just took the best shit available and the,
what's the most recent science on this stuff.
And we try to sell you the best supplements that we can get this.
We sell kettle bells now and battle ropes,
all things that I think are the,
the best pieces of equipment as far as for strength and conditioning.
There's some of the best exercises.
Equipment you can have.
Kettle bells are amazing.
If you've never done it before,
there's a hundred videos online you could be,
you know,
on youtube there's also a,
we have,
uh,
Keith Weber's,
extreme kettlebell cardio workout DVD for,
and we're actually going
to make our own.
I want to take people through a,
one of my fucking savage kettlebell routines and he get to see what kind of
crazy shit I do.
Fuck that noise.
But you can do it.
You don't have to do it,
but you can do it.
Uh,
but we sell a all sheet different sizes up to,
I think we have over a hundred pounds,
but the ones I use over between 35 and 70 is this.
It's the people that ordered the over the a hundred pound ones like distract
track.
These people are,
they like you like getting in touch with these people like you are now lead
lieutenant of the Joe Rogan Army.
You've got to keep those people in close proximity.
They're the ones who can do extreme physical things.
You're like a Google of warriors.
That's what you're doing here at on it,
aren't you?
We're trying to put together the strongest human beings possible.
We're trying to help people become a strong as possible.
Look,
having a strong body is fucking awesome if you don't think it is because you've
never had a strong body like the,
when someone can give you a jar of mayonnaise and always know that you're going
to be the guy that opens up bitch when you have to pick something up and you can
because your body can do it.
You can't.
You don't have to call somebody and,
Oh man,
I need some help.
I'll fuck now.
You can just hoist it up yourself cause your body works really good.
I don't know why anybody wouldn't want that.
To me,
that is a really weird sort of a distinction that people have made where they
try to separate intelligence from physical performance and that somehow or
another,
well,
I spend my time being intelligent.
I don't have any time for physical performance,
but yeah,
you exist in the same world that I do.
I know this world.
This world is very physical and for you to not enhance your physical body makes
me think you're dumb.
You're dumb in some way.
No.
If your,
if your,
if your physical body work better,
your life would be enhanced.
But I,
unless your,
your physical parts are just like laying on the couch and podcasting and
fucking,
you're a very rare,
I don't need to be,
I don't need to be fit to did though.
If you don't,
you think you'd have more energy.
You can fuck those girls better than stick around longer and I spent those boner
pills or fourth gone.
You don't need to do anything.
Just take one those boner pills,
they can't take it.
Do you remember what Tim Ferriss said?
That some acid reflex.
Remember what Tim first I though about this no biological free lunch.
Like you're paying for that for to,
for you to get that,
that does crazy super boners from these boner pills.
I got to think that somewhere on the other end of that,
well what it does is it makes all your blood goes to your Dick.
Right.
I consider that like,
you know,
like helping the flow of blood throughout your body more active.
Well this shit,
you're right actually.
And in fact,
they actually use whatever the fuck the active ingredient in product Fadil or
some of the record is in Viagra as a performance enhancing supplement.
I believe it's banned now by Olympic committees.
Why?
But because it makes you a [inaudible] has a very similar response to these
nitric oxide,
uh,
supplements,
which are all the rage and what some of them are actually fucking dangerous.
Like they,
they,
that Jack Three d people die on that shit.
Like a woman just died.
She was a,
a marathon runner in London,
like 26 years old.
Get take some Jack Three d runs a marathon.
Boom.
Her ticker just fucking blows.
And if she was laying on the couch watching fucking TV,
she would still be alive.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Like,
look at this guy,
this vis bode Miller on on it.
Bodie buddy Cody Cody.
He's like a famous skier.
I know.
Look at that shit.
Could you imagine doing that shit?
I could,
but man,
I have a friend,
a very good friend who was on the US ski team,
Doctor Steve.
He's calling the show for when we're explaining the a cyborg physique,
the female Cyborg and how,
how is that possible?
But doctor Steve was on the US ski team and he has massive fucking scars all
over his legs.
He's had,
I believe,
some insane number,
like 25 26 surgeries on his knees.
Incredible.
The covers of his knees,
whereas cartilages with so chewed away that they resurfaced it with like,
it looks like steel.
I mean,
I don't know what it is.
It's like some shiny metal,
I don't know whether it's titanium or what the fuck it is,
but they resurface that,
the caps of his fucking bones.
So he doesn't have bone on bone contact anymore.
So this cap sits on the bone and it just,
the roll together,
he's kind of like everything in his knees fucked.
He said everything replaced.
Like just last year he had another ACL operation.
I mean it's just over and over and over again.
This guy.
And so when I see skiing,
that's what I see.
I see knees.
Yeah.
I say,
hey,
laying on the couch,
this would not happen.
So this is what I'm saying.
I say balance my friend,
is it balanced and everything?
I've had a few operations and my body works great though.
You only have so many heartbeats Joe in the more you use them.
That's not true.
It is true.
No,
it's not true.
Do you think that fat people's hearts just beat it extra fast and that's why
they died off quick?
Yeah.
No.
Being Obese,
your body's not just not healthy.
I would imagine if you did,
if you actually did only have a hundred you know,
a certain amount of heartbeats and there's,
that was the key.
The key was just like
just staying calm.
But then what about good movies?
What about blowjobs?
What about a lot of shit that gets your heart rate up?
Well that's okay,
but if you're spending an hour a day doing it time 50 you know that's a lot of
heartbeats.
Instead of like getting like a quick blow job.
That's,
you mean if an hour,
a day of exercise,
hardcore exercise as opposed to your regimen of [inaudible] job in TV.
Don't you think though you would like have better performance in this podcasting
and in,
in your life.
Just have to move my face a lot so you're just happy with your body.
Just doing the minimum amount and get you from point a to point B because I
don't want a thousand knee surgeries.
I don't want to fucking ringworm on my asshole.
Look at any of that shit.
I want to,
I want to be clean and and and luck.
Luxurious for women so that they will be scared.
homey.com okay.
You're a fucking pussy.
I'll be scared.
A little ring worm on your butt hole.
Brody Miller.
Bodie.
Cody Miller.
Yeah.
Looking at that guy.
Skiing is kind of fuck it looks like a fucking tron guy.
Yeah.
It doesn't even look like a Ninja.
How fast do you think he's going to?
Probably like 50 or 60 fucking miles an hour,
right?
Dad,
look at his poles.
All Ben didn't know shit silly.
That's trippy as ridiculous to an out of mushrooms.
He must be fucking flying right there.
Ooh,
I snowplow and I don't ever go that far.
The scariest thing for me is the same people that are doing those,
those things where they drop them off a helicopter on a snowboard and they'd go
down the side of a fucking mountain.
Yeah.
Those guys are,
and I'm moles and that's how he times,
sorry,
I just going to say it.
And sometimes like they get caught in avalanches and the avalanche is like
behind them as they're coming down it terrifying to watch.
That's why you guys have this strong bone and joint Bolling choices are no g at
the end of that cause that's the actual active ingredients called strong.
I don't have my up my computer in front of me.
I Google you the uh,
the ingredients.
Um,
I forgot to bring my laptop.
Do you want to borrow one?
Yeah,
I dunno.
I got a mini,
I'm not sure.
Yeah,
maybe just in case I need to Google some shit.
Cause I do often times talk out of my ass and I like to correct myself.
Let's see if there's battery here.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com and check out the full range of supplements.
And again,
use a codename Rogan.
You'll save yourself 10% off.
That doesn't apply to the fitness equipment because we literally sell it as
cheap as humanly possible.
As far as I know that we have the,
the cheapest battle ropes that you can get on the Internet and that's another
great workout.
A piece of equip.
Who else sells battle ropes?
I thought you guys were done under oh there's other guys.
Yeah,
sure.
Like you know,
people that are really in the strength and fitness,
you know,
um,
I want to bring,
start bringing a few other things.
I'm thinking maybe I'm different things to do.
Chin ups with Chin ups I think are very important part of working out as well.
I'm thinking maybe even some of those soft ball handles.
We grab a softball and do chin ups with it.
It's really great for you to grip.
You know like so you can have a like our boy Alex Honnold get that kind of grip
scale buildings and shit.
See what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah.
Hey,
talk to her.
Lasar or laser laser do these kind of books.
Chelsea even existing where where you have like old books and stuff.
Because now it's just like,
you know,
a touch of gray or whatever and stuff.
It's not that classy looking,
but yeah.
Old dudes love that look,
that look of the shiny outside of the book of the most likely never fucking red.
They love that shit and it's like Shit like Pinocchio,
right?
Like Pinocchio and Joel's.
Yeah.
Quite honestly,
I trust you.
Wait,
laughs.
If I go over your house and you have a lot of that shit,
if you have books like that,
I really,
I will think you're a manufacturer person.
What are you reading?
Oh,
Peter Pan.
That's,
that's nice.
Well,
it's not even that.
It's like,
look at the volume.
Look at how those books look.
I mean like who is this guy?
What?
What the fuck are you buying?
Where are you buying these [inaudible] you just getting this all as a big set
that makes you look classing.
What is this?
I bet there's some secrets in these books.
I bet you open it up with this fucking guns and they're cutout.
Every one of them's got a gun in it.
Get it's Reptilian.
Could you imagine if every one of his fucking books was actually just a gun
holder and this whole time he's smiling and then one day the dot.
If someone goes to pick up the book and he,
they pick up the wrong one or gun falls out and I'm like,
what the fuck?
And then they realize,
dude had a hundred guns who's just super compulsive and he collected handguns
and put them inside books,
right?
That's why none of those,
nobody wants to ever read those books.
If you have one of those Shiny Bang books with the old style binding,
it's real,
super fancy.
You have one of those in your shelf.
Who the fuck's gonna pick that up and read it?
Even a robber's not going to read that.
No one would ever touch it.
This is subliminal of paint.
Big Penis says right here.
The only way someone's going to touch that as if you left a little kid in the
room by himself.
That's the only way those books getting touched,
but a grown adult,
we'll do that.
That's like DNA.
When you reverse him.
Look at verse eight he becomes say tonic and then all that shit becomes DNA.
Well,
this is rude because it's kind of like works for on it.
Oh,
obviously he's not really reptilian laser gentlemen.
He's or he's,
he's world renowned.
Neurophysicist you shouldn't do this to his image,
dude.
He worked in fuckhead my books Skyworks four on it.
I know.
You probably shouldn't do this to go and look.
If he gets mad,
he's happy about it.
You don't know about that.
You can't do that.
Well,
look at this picture.
That's not him.
Anyway.
Scan on to who he really is.
Yeah.
That's funny.
That's idea.
Is that a photo shop?
Did you use Photoshop?
This you've no,
I promise you.
Well that is hilarious.
Maybe that's what he used to look like,
but then they said on it said,
listen man,
for the,
for the DVD can hook a biker and we're going to do an interview with you.
We need you to really dress up,
doctor lasered and analyze this better
done at the technology.
We will all apologies to the good doctor.
We were just joking around and uh,
we,
we appreciate his,
uh,
he's a neurosurgeon,
this gentleman,
and uh,
he,
uh,
is a big fan of Alpha brain and he's kind of fat Rolex watch.
Sporty.
All right.
Go to go to on a.com.
That's [inaudible] and it used the codename Rogan and save yourself 10% off any
and all supplements are apologies,
doctor laser.
I love he had doctor laser.
He's just my son around this guy.
He's,
he's Wacky,
but you get,
you get to love them.
Trust me right now.
I know.
It's weird.
It's tenuous,
but trust me,
he's a good dude.
All right to the podcast.
Fuck.
Okay.
Powerful.
Brian red band.
It's just you and me buddy.
We haven't done this one of these for a while and it's crazy for me.
Did you,
have you got a little laptop and I got to get the charger.
Okay.
The,
um,
we're waiting for freeway.
Rick Ross,
I should say.
I say freeway.
Rick Ross,
because we have to make the distinction between him and the guy who was the
rapper who calls himself Rick Ross,
who says he got his nickname through some other,
he has got some wacky,
it's explanation for why he has the same name as this guy who was once an
actual,
a huge drug dealer who was actually involved unbeknownst to him,
to the whole Iran Contra scandal because back when the CIA or whoever the hell
it was was,
uh,
illegally selling drugs,
in Los Angeles to fund covert operations overseas that they didn't want to get
approval for it.
It's really kind of crazy shit.
This guy was involved in that.
Unbeknownst to him,
he was just out there slang and it was just out this slang in and didn't realize
that he was making so much money because he was sort of in cahoots with Uncle
Sam.
Well,
not even Uncle Sam,
just,
you know,
corrupt aspects of Uncle Sam.
I mean,
I'm sure you can't say all of Uncle Sam's corrupt.
That would be pretty douchey.
Do you think we got to our yesterday?
I think we did.
Yeah.
I kind of felt bad.
You feel bad.
Why?
Because it's seemed like,
it very reminded me of just,
how are you thinking like this?
Like,
like,
Oh shit,
maybe we should have done this off the air because maybe this is like he's going
through some shit.
Like maybe he's smoking too much weed.
Like maybe he's fucking like,
what if he is smoking?
Just mad amounts?
Well it definitely is,
but I don't think it's that.
I just think it's a matter of our is a very smart guy.
And when you,
when you're a smart person and you see something that's really stupid,
you can have a really adverse reaction to it where it gets a logical and he's,
uh,
he's allowing himself to get a logical,
and he's allowing himself to get upset at those people.
And the end result is you're not really being victimized.
You're,
yes,
you're,
you're losing a little bit of the privacy of what you bring on board.
But we,
we understand that and we know we're going to do that.
But I think Ari had to relook at it.
And I think once he did,
he started like seeing it a different way,
which shows you how smart he is to know that he can get caught up in a fucked up
way of thinking.
But it's just that can happen to you.
Yeah.
He can get caught up in a fucked up way of thinking and it's,
it's not beneficial.
It's not,
and it's not the only way you could look at it,
but it seems like it is at the time.
At the time it just seems like the way go and you're like,
no,
fuck that.
But really,
you know when you look at all this shit to be pissed at,
that's not,
that's not up there.
Yeah.
And you could tell you what he was kind of realizing it know,
so near the end of it,
you can tell he was second guessing himself.
All right,
well you know his,
his point about the seats,
the plane seats makes more sense,
but still,
he's our,
he's a good dude.
He's a,
he really is a good person.
He's just got,
you know,
he's got a little,
a little better anger that comes out of him sometimes when it comes to certain
things and when,
when he gets angry about something,
like it's very hard for him to look at any other point of view.
But that's super common.
You know,
a lot.
I've,
I used to have that a lot.
I used to have a real problem with once I got angry about something I can never
think that,
uh,
it was my fault that it started in the first place.
I always try to justify it for myself and then I had to like look at that and
I'm like,
wait,
why am I,
why am I making excuses for this?
Like,
look at this for what it actually is.
what,
what actually is going on there?
It's very hard to do and a lot of people are bad at it,
you know?
And it doesn't mean that you're a bad person.
It means you can get caught in a fucked up way of thinking and so you'll just
snap,
you know?
And for Ari could have been something else.
It could have been a girl problem.
It could have been,
who knows?
It could have been a little bit on edge.
And then you get in front of somebody and then they do something that you think
is just so stupid,
just fucking still.
And then before you know it,
you're,
you don't even know what you're doing.
You're just yelling at someone and you know you're not,
you're not taking a big deep breath and going,
what is this really?
You know,
how,
how much of it an inconvenience is this?
How much should I be reacting?
What is really going on here?
I see a bunch of people doing their job and the ultimate goal is to stop playing
from blowing up.
It's Ah,
you know,
but that's once you're there,
once you're at 10 you know,
like he was like,
he was yelling at them and shit like he was,
he was at 10 he was at,
he was at the point where I was lost.
I was going,
God damn it,
I'm going to have to get a fucking lawyer.
I'm going to have to call a lawyer.
Like,
how do I get a guy out of jail?
I've never had to get somebody out of jail.
So if Ari gold,
if he gets arrested,
I'm like,
fuck,
what do I have to do here?
You know,
he needs,
he seems like he needs to get back into doing Jujitsu.
Like he seems like he has these rage issues,
you know,
like in the past too with,
like Bobby and with that,
with all that other stuff.
And I think
it would certainly help him if he had some sort of serious exercise.
But I don't think he's really into it.
Yeah,
he does.
Um,
basketball.
I know he does that like once a week or something like that.
Yeah.
But not basketball with black guys basketball.
He plays basketball with little comics.
All the cigarettes.
Yeah.
It's so true.
True that basketball is a joke kind of cardio.
Those fucks have.
Oh yeah.
I think Mervin is sound of,
you know,
murders.
He's this big guy that plays one of the,
the capital one commercial vikings.
He's on the basketball team.
Awesome.
This guy's a huge guy.
Oh,
that's funny.
The capital one vikings commercial,
you know,
like,
do you buy things based on cool commercials?
Do you ever do that?
Ah,
no,
but it really,
it really tells me like,
Hey,
like so knows,
I don't know if anyone has so notices this is a company that has this Bluetooth
speaker and it's fucking,
it sounds amazing.
I bought them for my whole family for Christmas.
Uh,
it's just a little blue speed.
You go on your iPhone and it just,
it's,
it's great.
And uh,
as an extra small,
like a rectangle,
right?
Yeah.
It's like a little little box.
There's a little blue in the center of it.
I just got it.
It's,
it's great.
It's one of my favorite things ever.
Especially like in your bedroom,
just,
yeah.
What was I talking about now?
Oh,
you're so high.
Look at you.
What were we just talking about?
You're talking about,
I know a Bluetooth,
I don't know shit.
What?
Commercials buying something.
Oh,
they have this really cool commercial.
As an example,
I was like,
what is this Bluetooth speaker?
And I went on Amazon and read some reviews and stuff like that.
And I did kind of,
it Kinda made me go,
well if they have such a cool commercial,
they are a coal company.
Cause you know they have a cool marketing company,
they have a cool advertising company they hired.
I mean have you ever gone to someone's website and you know they suck but the
website's awesome.
Yeah.
Let me just hired so many cool,
right?
I figured it out.
Yeah,
but there's a certain ads we're like,
you know,
out of respect,
you see the ad,
you'll your buy shit.
Like I know somebody who buys Geico because she thinks the Geico ad is
hilarious.
Right.
So she's always like,
she's like,
you ever seen the one when pigs can fly?
Yeah.
It's so much better than like say progressive.
I don't want to fuck that girl.
Why you hit her?
We got away from it.
Okay.
That's not true.
A lot of guys want to fuck that girl.
Really Progressive Group or I don't want that.
A lot of dudes have a type like that,
I guess.
Do you have a,
do you have a weird type?
Yeah,
Asian
at all.
They're amazing men.
For white people from Ohio.
That's about as exotic cars yet.
Right?
They're cute too.
Yeah.
They're like little toys,
Asian girls.
Very attractive.
I don't know.
Did you like,
did you always like Asians?
Not Oh yeah.
Um,
I think uh,
Asians are,
uh,
the,
the idea for white guys.
Whoa,
it's exotic.
This is crazy.
She's like another species and they're super smart.
You know,
you get all the danger without dating a black check,
you know,
you get,
you get all the,
the danger of being around someone alien culture.
Yeah.
But he gives us exotic sex girl that's like,
you know,
thought to be like really submissive and you know,
like that's what people was a little like the Asian girls will stay in their
place and there'll be submissive and take care of their man.
And like guys will say,
Oh,
I got an Asian wife.
I'll tell you what,
I'll never go back to white girls again.
A lot of guys say shit like that.
You know?
Is it a certain part of your age that you become a Vietnam Vietnam vet?
Like,
like,
dude,
like that you just get into Asians like hardcore because it seems like listening
to that question,
if you,
if you use that right
question,
you could use that in court to the judge to like if on paper,
the way that's where that question was written there,
they would like,
it would take away whoever's taking care of you.
They would bring it to somewhere else that says something wrong with his
development.
Look at the way he's talking.
I knew this one Asian girl that she would clean me every night and it was,
she put lotion under my eyes and then clean my fingers and make that popping
noise and stuff and like,
Whoa,
you this for professional.
Like how do you know to do that popping noise on your fingers and then taking
care of you and washes me what that wash cloth.
It's amazing.
But then you know,
normal girls are just like trying to puke and like your trashcan and stuff and
then,
well,
yeah,
I mean will you get in real personal here fellow,
but um,
your situation,
uh,
you know,
without talking about it.
Yeah.
I mean you got told us about my current situation,
right?
Know it's not your current situation,
but that situation that Greg,
you know,
you either get that and you have a nice girl who takes care of you or you go on
wild freak sex orgies when you're on extra.
So
those are your two options in this world that you find yourself in.
You're presented with very unique challenges.
You know,
not a lot of people have those,
those problems.
You know,
with the most guys,
the problem was actually just getting laid.
You,
it's a,
the problem is trying to figure out,
you know,
it's,
it's a crazy world,
but when you're talented,
when you're in a position,
when you have some people paying attention to you,
you get like superpowers and you,
you've right now you got freak superpowers.
So you've got to deal with that.
And the only way to deal with that as either you go on a fuck rampage or you
find a good one,
you settled down.
Those are your two options because uh,
you know,
you either you either use that power for evil and they go out there and spread
your super aids
or,
or are you a,
you find a good girl.
The problem is finding someone that you actually like and then finding someone
that you can actually tolerate for long periods of time and then like actually
still enjoying being around them.
It's so rare.
It's so rare and it's not necessarily the man's problem.
It's not necessarily the woman's problem.
It's like the eye,
the odds of you finding someone that whatever's wrong with them fits in with
whatever's wrong with you.
And they both like clank and then like fit in perfect and you actually enhance
each other.
You actually make each other's lives better.
You can do that,
but it's fucking stupid.
Hard to find,
you know,
it is possible but you're definitely not going to find it when you're doing
those coke ecstasy
binge situations.
Like,
then you're just,
it's all about rehydrating and then you know,
finding out how long do you have to wait before you dig and get hard again every
day with those pillows,
Joe?
Yeah,
but I'm telling you,
man,
you might break something in your brain.
I don't think you're supposed to take shit every day.
I don't actually,
well w I would say once a week I do that.
It's like you're so crazy.
You don't,
even by the pharmaceuticals,
you just go to that fucking drugstore counter Mexican Tacos,
go get that shit at the gas station that's sitting on the front counter.
I think I had to get one at seven 11 the other day.
What the fuck's in there?
I know I got this one at seven 11 yet.
The other day I showed you in Vegas that says on the big thing,
it's like a,
it's like watch out for counterfeits,
but it's printed onto the box.
Like,
why would they even say watch out for counterfeits and it was such a huge symbol
and then on the back it was like also peel this off off if you want to use it as
a calling card or something like,
so it was a calling card slash a dick pill thing.
You could like use like long distance.
You can make it like a gift card.
Like when you go to it like a gift card place.
It was,
I don't know,
it was fucking weird gift card.
Are you talking about a calling card?
Like for like a payphone?
It was like the payphone.
Yeah.
It was just like they still sell those.
Do they still remember when 800 collect?
Remember when that was around?
That was a big thing.
There was all those uh,
when 800 collect companies remember that there was like,
no,
there was a sprint one.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
They would offer you what did,
what are those things that are offering you like a phone that you use through
the Internet?
What does that still goes on?
But it's like a late night commercial.
It's a phone that works in the,
it cuts your costs down.
I the guys dialing internationally.
Like what is it like a Skype phone,
is that right?
Yeah.
What's that Mr Jack off or something along those lines?
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
you plug it in and it just pretty much does what like Skype does.
It's just like a USB thing that you attach like headphones too or something like
that if I remember correctly.
But that's all it is.
So it's not like an actual phone,
it's just like what you know,
like charter or Skype is,
are any of these voice over and then you have to do the dialing through a
computer?
No,
I think you could set it up where you can you,
I don't know.
I think if there's like a phone jack in it,
that's what it was.
It's a phone Jack on one side.
On the other side.
It was a USB plug.
And what it does is it just pretty much converts your phone into a voice over
the Internet so it makes it,
so you're using Skype with but with a phone line.
So it will ring in it.
It's,
Eh,
why bother with that?
Yeah.
Well that seems like it was kind of around more when it used to cost money to
like be like in other states with your phone.
Right.
Most people don't have like out of state roaming,
right.
I don't know anyone.
You don't have issues without a state.
Like I,
as far as I know like the,
the minute some I have Verizon,
I can use it all over the country and I'm not roaming.
Right,
right.
But remember if you used to like drive just a little bit out of your house,
you were fucking roaming.
You would be in some area where you don't really have coverage.
So you have to use someone else's coverage.
Some other company and they bill your phone coming and your phone company bills
you like double or triple or whatever the fuck it was.
And for then back then there was,
there was a deal to like make a long distance call.
Holy Shit.
Long distance calls were crazy.
Do you remember when they had phones and planes?
That's one of the only pieces of technology that slipped backwards was the
phones and plain.
That's right.
You never see that in.
Never see that.
You don't,
when you used to open up your seat in inside your console,
there was a phone he'd slide a credit card down at and you'd enter in your card
information and then you would fucking use the phone.
You know why?
You know why they don't want you to turn on your cell phones and work?
Because now they don't want anyone that described the terrorist events because
they're all undercover,
you know,
government agents and there's really no hijackers.
It's like that.
You know what I mean?
Like they don't want communication just in case if they have to take down
another plane.
Joan's way of looking at the situation,
it's very clear.
These people don't want you making calls.
These people are the enemies of liberty.
If you're,
um,
if you're on a plane and some shit goes down,
now you just have to draw pictures
bad.
It'd be like a sketch artist at a fucking courthouse.
That's right.
Is that not one of the stupidest gigs ever?
Like,
let's,
uh,
well,
you know,
we can,
you can show what happened,
but you can't be really,
really good about describing it.
So only draw it.
We have s that's show,
I do Monday,
we have a sketch artist that draws and we had this guy do a,
a doctor who,
uh,
drawing sketch artist for real are like a last,
that is what is that?
This is,
we have every show,
but what does that picture?
So just from doctor who,
and then all our faces are in,
in the stomach.
There's me and there's Brody
sketch artists are seriously that,
that the only,
not the artists themselves are just people with a Gig.
But the idea behind it is seriously one of the most arcane aspects of our,
our judicial system.
It's fucking ridiculous.
When you see those photos on TV,
when a guys in court and you see the,
the TV shows you,
the new shows you a drawing.
Like,
look,
what the fuck am I sitting here?
That is to me like such a sign of like a fucking dorky world that it's so,
it's so screwed up and ridiculous and so nonsensical that they'll,
they'll film or a drawing of some stuff that happened in a time where
photographs exist.
It's not like they're not pretending that they have no idea what happened in
that courthouse.
We have no news for,
you know,
we had a guy in there but they wouldn't let him take pictures,
but they would let them draw.
You'd be like,
what?
Who the fuck's in charge here?
You'd,
you'd pull them over and go,
what is this?
Why is this here?
Why are we doing here?
Let them take a fucking picture.
It's 2013 asshole.
You don't need to draw pictures.
Take a fucking
why did,
did they do that though?
Because for someone,
one's a lie.
Someone wants to be able to lie.
Someone wants to be able to control the access to the images that get displayed
from a situation.
Someone wants to be able to control the situation.
That's all it is.
If they wanted the American public,
which they should have,
especially in cases of criminal cases,
we have to worry about whether or not this person's a bad person.
They're out there like trying to victimize people.
They're trying to limit your access to the,
to how the court works to limit your access to how,
uh,
what,
what actually takes place in a courtroom.
Because a lot of times it's bullying.
You know,
there's a lot of bullshit that goes on in court.
There's a lot of shit that goes on in court.
Did you know the people that get charged with medical marijuana when they get
arrested,
they get arrested federally most of the time.
And they're not even allowed to use the word medical.
They can't say medical marijuana.
They just sold marijuana.
Like if they use the word medical,
they're just throw him in jail.
It says contempt of court.
They'll throw you in jail because they don't believe that marijuana is a
medicinal substance or it's not their law.
The federal government,
they're allowed to say that there is no law.
So you can't say medical marijuana.
So even though you're defending yourself in the same country as where medical
marijuana is legal,
you're not even allowed to bring it up in a federal court if that's not some
crazy bullying,
you know,
it's stupid that that day they could censor that.
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
It just,
it's w I mean if,
if people knew about these things,
if you're watching video footage of courts,
you know,
constant,
you know?
Yeah.
I know they had court TV for awhile.
That was kind of fascinating.
That was like our first time,
I think it wasn't that popular.
Mostly cases sucked and quite honestly,
there's a lot of shit that's more interesting than watching trials all day.
And then they had the Oj trial though.
That was on court TV too,
wasn't it?
Yeah,
I think so.
That was on everything.
Now remember that that was like a television event that was kind of like Oliver
North where every channel was all about,
well,
all of our north,
who was the first time we really were pretty sure that a celebrity has killed a
woman.
Like we're pretty sure you know,
there was some speculation about other people in the past.
I have Kennedy and Marilyn Monroe.
No.
Yes.
Kennedy.
Marilyn Monroe.
Yeah.
A lot of people thought that Marilyn Monroe was talking too much shit,
but that's what they would always think she could.
She could have been that.
She was just a crazy bitch.
Did a lot of pills or whatever and died.
I heard she gave him herpes.
Holy Shit.
You heard that.
He started it.
Here's the patient zero in the herpes war.
Did herpes exists before the 16th when with herpes invented?
I bet it's been around forever.
If I had to guess,
I'd say that shit came from France.
Won The patient zero's from France.
A guarantee Ya.
Ooh.
I was actually under a video search on Google when I search for herpes first.
Oh,
the show too on video.
Yeah.
Shingles is apparently a type of herpes genital that shingles is like that shit
that some people would get this bad breakouts all over the back.
Yeah,
I know somebody that has that.
It's supposed to be horrible.
Yeah.
I heard somebody got chicken pockets.
I rare chickenpox the other day at some famous person
and she had had already had chicken pox,
so it was her second chicken park.
I thought that's never supposed to.
I know like it was somebody like weird,
like Betty White or somebody.
Why is,
yeah,
if you're that old man,
you get chicken pox,
you're fucked when you're really old,
you have to wash your hands all the time.
That that should be a meme.
My,
if I was going to make fun of me and my points on a unmedical science,
if you're really old,
you should wash your hands a lot,
but you really should,
you know,
that's,
they say that's one of the best ways to prevent diseases.
Just uh,
not constant,
don't get nutty,
but uh,
keep your fucking hands clean.
That's where you pick up most of it.
I guess going from hand to mouth,
you don't even realize it.
It's Kinda rude that we have this a weird war going on between our bodies and
these strange little things that attack us,
that make us feel like shit and literally weaken your body and they're so
common.
They happen every year.
There's a whole season when the attack and some,
sometimes they get people,
some people die off.
People that avoid medication,
people that are old,
people with compromised immune systems.
Colds get them every year.
It's crazy.
It's like we don't even think about it,
but colds are monsters.
They're just not that effective.
Actually,
Barbara Walters hit with chicken pox,
or rare,
a rare version of it.
Did say she had it already?
No,
I thought it Sunday.
Yeah.
Why is she knocked vaccinated?
She is an 83
Mama.
Well,
this is a lot of words.
Yeah.
That sucks though.
Not that can't be fun.
Yeah.
This is one of those weird fucking things like the mumps,
when the mumps comes around,
like what is going on?
What is this shit?
Where's this coming from?
Like how does that work that all of a sudden some kid has the mumps,
there's a mumps outbreak in New Jersey.
Who was the first to get that mumps?
Like how does that,
how does the something like that reemerge.
Yeah.
Or that that other disease that supposedly porn just got back into porn.
That was really,
oh yeah.
Was that syphilis.
Syphilis.
Yeah.
That's super
dangerous.
That shit kills the fuck out of you.
I think syphilis is what got Al Capone.
I'm pretty sure.
I think syphilis does horrible things to you before it kills you to,
it's really bad.
Oh,
hilarious.
Court TV is now true TV.
Really and true TV is the fakeness of all TV show channel.
So that's crazy.
Court TV is like,
you know what,
we're losing
money on real.
Let's go get some fake money.
Let's get some fake.
I was watching that,
that,
that show.
I just got into that storage wars show.
Oh this is so stupid.
It's,
it's one of my,
it's so addicting because want to see what's inside this things and I'm
thinking,
why doesn't like,
all right,
these storage companies,
uh,
auction these off,
right.
Why don't they just go through it and then sell everything and become and make a
ton of money?
These storage companies,
well,
I'm pretty sure that it's 100% horseshit.
Well,
if that does happen though,
they do have auctions at storage and watching those shows,
they are not taking any chances.
Right.
As to whether or not they find shit.
They just pretend to fly and shit.
Are you sure that that's a fake show?
I'm almost positive that a good percentage of all reality TV is fuckery.
That what you're seeing is overproduced fuckery.
That's why when you watch it,
it's real obvious when you watch.
Like I watch,
I told you I watched a whole episode of Jersey shore where the whole episode was
about,
well that's fake.
Yeah.
One Dude wanting to leave the situation,
wanted to leave.
Snookie want to stay.
That's the whole episode.
The situations like C'mon,
let's get outta here and stuff.
He's like,
Yo,
he wanted to fucking leave.
Fuck him and these are,
come on,
I gotta get Outta here.
Like there was the whole episode and you know that they like they can cock these
fucking things.
I mean they decide that there's going to be some sort of an issue.
Okay,
here's the issue.
Ready Go.
When,
when,
uh,
they were trying to do mining store,
that was one of the reasons why Dunkin didn't want to be involved cause like it
was going to be orchestrated.
Like they were going to have like,
this is what it's going to happen.
You're going to go looking for some Mexican food.
You can't find it.
You look for some Chinese food,
it doesn't look good,
and you go and finally you get to sell on this and like they had like a script
and they worked it out.
It's like it's a sketch.
It's just to see really bad sketch with no creativity instead of,
it's not reality.
You know,
like following guy around.
It's like a sketch about someone finding an old record player and a storage
container.
All my goodness is this.
This could be worth a lot of money.
We bitch.
You know exactly what that's worth.
You put it there.
You're fucked.
That's what you're watching.
You're watching shitty sketched TV.
Why wouldn't they just do real one
then?
Because it's more fun for them to be able to orchestrate it.
But even the fake ones would be crazy.
I'm sure they're finding bodies and sometimes sometimes you don't find anything.
Sometimes you find a bag of newspapers.
Then what the fuck do you do?
Sometimes you find a guy who collected newspaper.
Oh Great.
He's got 100,000 issues of the New York Times here every day for the last fifth.
What the fuck?
You'd be so bored if,
I bet you got to go through a lot of storage containers for you.
Find something wacky so you can't just keep filming and you can't keep buying
these things and either Kinky,
rolling the dice,
you might go into one and there's nothing in there.
So I think if I know the way the studio's thank you know they,
they want to maximize their cash though.
Listen,
this,
is there any,
is anyone opposed US fucking leaving a body here.
Let's just leave out of here.
They'll go get a fake body.
They'll put a body at and then let's say we found body,
the one of the fucking line,
the one guy on the show,
I forget his name,
but he just goes the whole time.
He just cause Yup.
And he has like wears hats that say up on it and shirts and his car.
So that's up on it.
This thing.
Yeah,
that's his thing.
Trademark.
Oh my God.
He trademark.
Yup.
Somebody should drop our media in his head.
How do you trademark?
Yep.
Is that even possible?
Well,
I think you have to,
it has to be like his belt is why you uup or something like that.
So it's more of like a,
it's not a real word or sentence
gross.
I can't even watch that show.
I've only watched it a couple times,
but one of the guys who left didn't,
one of the guys who left side,
I'd say it was all bullshit.
There was all staged.
It was the second guy that,
yup.
Guy.
Oh really?
He said it was all staged.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I might not listen to him,
but I ain't think I know.
Maybe.
Maybe it's just a drama queen.
Yeah.
Maybe it'll
lying bitch and he's just trying to ruin the whole show.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe big foot hunters are really looking for bigfoot.
Finding bigfoot.
Yeah.
They keep,
they keep doing the same show over and over again.
They have to find something.
Did you ask Tyson about bigfoot?
Uh,
do not know because that would be weird to see if him would,
I wanted to ask him about space stuff also because that's his specialty.
But,
um,
yeah,
I would like to see his take the rhythm really fascinating.
Uh,
uh,
professional take on it is the Jane Goodall take.
That one really sways me because,
uh,
obviously I'm no scholar of primatology and I don't really know that much about
apes.
I just know what I've read and documentaries and stuff,
but I've never liked formally studied it.
So when someone like Jane Goodall,
who when I was in high school,
you know,
we watched documentaries in class.
That was,
it was a Jane Goodall documentary and we read books about Jane Goodall and when
she says that she,
sure there's a undiscovered primate living in the Pacific northwest,
I go,
damn,
when she says that she believes in the Yeti as well.
She thinks it's probably the same animal.
Yeah.
But maybe,
you know,
she's getting older in her age and she picked a soul that she,
this is the journey.
She heck yeah.
Boy,
I got more tweets about Melissa Etheridge and the most athletes podcast and any
podcasts or recent seven,
Neil Tyson,
but people were either going nuts and loved it or they were like,
God Damn Melissa Etheridge is off her rocker.
Yeah,
well,
I mean half the time I was totally on board though.
You know,
it was just that once in a while where something came out that was like,
Ooh,
Yay.
Well,
you know what?
Her point of view,
it was really fascinating because like I said,
it's,
it's like a,
almost like a religious point of view.
It's like you're empowering yourself with this.
It's way,
way of looking at the world,
but it's like,
oh,
I dunno.
It's,
it's a tricky thing to think that you're creating your entire world and that
you,
you're controlling your own destiny like that.
It's very weird,
weird to not recognize that there's a lot of interactions and to ignore all of
them.
Like if you see all the interactions like on a street corner,
just see people walking across the street and see cars stopping and not stopping
and people texting and people not realizing that the light has turned green.
You see all that randomness.
You see people like on their phone with their hand up to their head and they
don't see a car that's merging to the right hand side because their head is
being covered by the phone.
That's,
that's really common.
You can control all that.
Okay,
and if you're there,
you're telling me that you that you were safe,
you're going to be okay because you haven't,
you haven't arranged to have this happened in your existence.
I say,
wow.
maybe though,
Shit,
I don't know.
She might be right you,
I mean,
what a strange thing it would be if we found out that all this time we,
what we were really lacking was just confidence and understanding of our
capabilities and that you really can completely manifest your own reality with
your mind and that you,
your whole world that you live in,
you can orchestrate with your mind.
Wow.
That,
I mean,
in the future,
one day that tone turns out that that's the next evolving capability of human
beings.
And then where they just weren't aware of it,
but some of them made it happen on their own and didn't know why they were doing
it.
And then the other ones made their life a complete and total mass.
But it was all essentially their own choice,
your own choice to do.
So,
yeah,
be fascinating.
But it's,
it's,
for me personally,
I see why she commits to it.
I see why it would be empowering and I see why it makes her feel like really
strong and powerful.
And I,
I,
I see all the benefit in it,
but my point of view is always way more.
Who the fuck knows?
There's way more.
Who the fuck knows to anything.
I can't confirm like for sure 100% I don't have anything in front of me that
tells me that that could be real.
I don't have anything.
It might be,
I mean it's one of those the possible scenarios the imagination could conjure
up,
you could conjure up a million different scenarios as to why you're here,
why you're built like you are while you have the interest you have.
You can come up with a million different combinations of hypothesis as to why
and what happens in the previous life if there is a previous life,
but you're really just making things up.
That's reality.
The really the reality is that you being in another dimension and you're
choosing this life,
like you're really just making that up.
I don't know if that might be real.
It might be real.
It absolutely might be real.
She almost was borderline talking about being similar simulation theory.
Meaning like,
like you chose the player,
you pick the outfit,
you know,
and then you went and like,
like she was almost saying that we played a game,
we,
we made our character and we chose the level that we were going to do,
where,
what part of the map we are going to live on.
And it was weird if he thought of it that way.
Like she always almost doing some kind of hippie version of this simulation
theory.
Yeah,
very much so.
Yeah.
I think the,
the people that believe in the secret and the people that believe in simulation
theory,
they,
there's definitely a crossover there,
right?
I mean if you really creating your own reality,
you know,
without fuck.
See that.
See the problem is reality is so slippery and weird that the idea that we're
creating our own reality,
it doesn't seem that far fetched.
You know,
if we found out that this world really is a simulation,
I don't think you would be that much different than it is right now.
Because if,
if we didn't know the world was the simulation,
you,
you know,
if there was no,
never was even a theory and you just looked at this world and you go,
well this is this making sense now this world is filled with shit that doesn't
make sense.
All the,
the,
I mean besides the marijuana laws and sketch sketch artists and court rooms and
there's a million fucking things and make no sense as a million things.
They're stacked up all over the place and then there's a million things that are
like so beyond our capability of the,
even the people that are enthusiasts and I'm like when it comes to cell phones
or when it comes to that Bluetooth device,
you were talking about the Sonos thing,
those things who are so outside of our,
our understanding we like can read that.
Oh,
Bluetooth is this bandwidth not,
you know,
one o eight one 11 be with,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
All right.
And it comes through this way.
Do you know how to make that?
Do,
do you know what you would have to do?
Do you know what reactions that are causing the interaction between those two
devices?
I have no fucking clue.
And these things exist right alongside sketch artists.
It's like it's all together like a giant joke.
It's like a joke of a movie and if you were going to make a simulation about the
wild west of the roaring twenties of the technological error,
it would look exactly like this day in time.
So if we really are players in a simulation,
it makes a lot of sense.
This the the the,
the B beyond bizarre nature of this reality that makes a lot of sense of it's
fake.
The problem is it sounds retarded.
You say that you sound like a fucking idiot beside like a Weirdo.
You sound like a dumb ass.
You sound like,
but scientists way smarter than us are the ones who are pro her proposing this.
It's not us.
Like I didn't invent the idea of simulation theory.
I became fascinated with it.
I talk about it all the time,
but it absolutely never came from my mind.
It came from me reading something that a scientist wrote about it or I was like,
what?
That it was not even a thought that I ever even the I the idea that the whole
world is like some sort of massive computer program.
Yeah,
it's craziness.
And this course is Joe.
Did you see this?
Uh,
this video right here yet?
It's a community access channel show.
I,
it's a guy that wants to be like one of those guys that go on like the tonight
show and brings the animals,
you know?
No,
but this is like,
like did amateur,
like this is the open mic of being one of those guys that this guy is the
biggest idiot in the world.
He just,
what he does,
he has a table and he puts a ton of animals on there and he mixes animals
together that are not supposed to be together like cats and birds.
Come on like,
check this,
check this out.
How old were you?
Okay,
come on.
That's one of my favorite ones.
A monkey and a bird.
Just think they taste good too.
Now when he's showing on my finger like this,
what I do is I tell him no and I poke my finger down his throat like that.
He gags and then he stops.
Okay,
now we let them do it again.
It's important to do this little while.
His teeth is small and he can't hurt me.
We tell them no.
Poke your finger down there.
Rick Ross is here.
Let's talk about that is here.
Yeah,
bird feathers.
I've wanted to write.
He's here to take care of.
As long as they have the right diet,
we're better off to just kicking away through north.
It's possible.
Have nothing to grip again,
so they're going to grow a lot faster than all.
The other thing I was getting on the floor.
Well,
oops,
a puppy round.
Other puppy.
It's important that you really work hard.
It's fair it on the floor.
Now it's important that you really work hard in obedience training.
Oh,
excuse me,
Bonnie.
All right off you have now this kid never saw a dog before,
so he's scared.
Okay,
okay.
Is the first time he's been here.
Now if you hold the kitten
up where they're always go,
no,
they chose to go inside.
Hospitals don't get a lot going to even appreciate it.
Mary,
what does it,
if they want to go the back,
it's under.
It's on live leak.
It's just what the fuck.
This shirt isn't animal planet.
It starts off.
It ends with like dogs and turtles.
Okay.
Shut the shit off.
See what happens when you're not here.
Rick Ross,
motherfuckers playing turtles are wrestling with cats and all kinds of man.
I apologize.
No worries man.
No worries.
They told me don't leave.
Oh really?
W This,
but ladies and gentlemen,
what we said before,
if you don't know who Rick is,
Rick is at one time inspiring tennis player in Los Angeles.
That was a young man that didn't have even the ability to read and became a
gigantic cocaine.
Kingpin wound up going to jail,
learn how to read.
Little became studied the law,
learn that they fucked him,
got out of jail because of and found out that there's a dude using his name
who's wrapper and it's the craziest thing ever.
His name.
You mean if you,
if you know rapping,
you know Rick Ross,
a lot of people like,
oh shit.
Rick Ross is going to be on the Joe Rogan podcast and they tune in and go,
who
the fuck is this guy?
Hey,
people stop me on the street all the time.
See Man,
I saw you on Joe Rogan.
MEDVEC hazy to me.
Show you to see it.
You put me in the tee shirt business.
What is it?
What is the real,
Rick Ross got a rapper by the way.
I dude came to my,
one of my Chicago shows.
He had one of those.
Hey,
this your work man.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
The real Rick Ross is not a rapper.
You don't what got me in a tee shirt?
Well,
I'm going to wear it.
I'll wear it with honors.
I bought you to here.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I wanted to thank you man,
for putting me up on that game.
If people want to buy them,
where can they get them?
Or they can go to a freeway.
So social media.com freeway,
social media.com there.
You're going to get hit with an avalanche right now.
You think they're going to support me?
I support the fuck are you man?
What the fuck are you going to get hit with an avalanche of orders?
You make that shirt look good man.
So one more time the website or they didn't write it down.
Freeway,
social media.com freeway,
social media.com and get yourself to real.
Rick Ross is not a rapper,
man.
You see the new business that Joe Rogan put me in?
You know what I'm saying?
Now,
not only am I selling tee shirts,
I started off selling tee shirts,
but now manufacturing them,
I'm putting them together and everything.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
You gave me a whole new career.
What's a great career too?
Because you know what,
man,
this guy's made a lot of fucking money off you.
You should make a lot of money off you too.
I hope so.
This is the way to do it.
To to,
you know,
to explain like what the fuck.
It's a crazy story,
man.
It is a dude running around pretending to be,
you almost got killed last weekend.
Was that real?
Because I know 50 cent in him.
If you don't know the whole gangster rap world,
this gentleman 50 cent and the fake Rick Ross did not like each other at all.
At all.
50 set.
Uh,
who I've mad.
He's very nice guy.
He apparently has been saying the whole thing was stage cause none of the
bullets hit the car.
It's amazing.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
I didn't get no car.
No Ak I heard it was an AK.
I don't know what it was.
Whoever it was was a horrible,
she trashed his Rolls Royce.
So worst shot ever.
If you've got a giant fat dude in front of you in a mercy,
what was a Rolls Royce?
Those worries and nice looking roads where it's still,
yeah he didn't,
I tell you something.
Makes a lot of stuff.
A lot of sense.
So you know,
I've thought about it after he said Dan cause cause I mean I couldn't,
you know,
I couldn't just grasp that at first.
And I'm like,
I mean,
who would go in in a community and,
and she can let our 15 rounds just in buildings and,
and how do you miss the,
how do you miss 15 times when,
I mean,
I guess you can the right circumstances,
but he's very lucky if he set that up.
If he actually would set something up like that with a real gun and shooting it
in occupied community.
I mean,
he may really wind up being a gangster one day in prison or it could be that
someone was just trying to scare him and that they weren't trying to kill him.
They're trying to get them to give money and if he gives him money,
you know,
you can't give money when you're dead.
So they don't really want to shoot him.
What they want to do is scare the shit out of him,
let him alone.
And that's when he crashed.
That's what I thought too.
That's what I feel.
And I felt that it was a warning shot.
You know,
pay what you owe,
uh,
you know,
and get on your business.
And for people don't know that side of the story apparently.
Like he use someone's name and a rap and there's,
uh,
a group of gentlemen that called themselves a gangster disciples and they
apparently the game a warning once and he did something else.
I was in jail with some of those guys.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They,
they don't enjoy his use of their vernacular.
And uh,
the,
the image that you mentioned,
who would,
who would want somebody to come represent their thing?
Something that you've worked hard for it to put together and then hit this guy
come in.
He hasn't paid any dues,
but he enjoys all the benefits.
It's a strange case of Americana in my opinion.
I find it quite fascinating because,
um,
you know,
we are in so many ways,
we're so silly with our culture and a are,
are going way out of the way to pretend to be something that we're not and
selling an image and you know,
and portraying an image and his case,
his story is one of the most fascinating ones that I've ever seen because he's
making all kinds of histories.
It's like,
remember the CV 40 the Chris Rock?
Yeah.
It's like an updated version of that.
He's a corrections officer.
I mean it sounds he's worse to CD four.
It sounds like you're writing a movie,
right?
A corrections officer who's known to be like,
did he like get like employee of the month and shit?
Did He,
did he got award?
Okay.
So he's like,
you know what you had to do to get award as a,
as a correction while vision.
What do you have to do?
Look at a lot of balls and assholes.
They got to find things.
That would be a job.
That would be a job that would suit me,
right?
If it was a female facility.
Oh yeah.
But what if you pull him dynamite,
a chick's pussies all day?
I do want to get a little paranoid,
be fine,
but at a men's facility,
uh,
I don't think so.
Not me.
I'm going to have to wait.
So the guy pretends to be this guy with this crazy criminal past of selling
drugs and he tattoos your name on his hands,
your name.
Rick Ross is tattooed on his hands.
He's got like money tattooed all over and all kinds of,
all the crazy shit.
It's really interesting.
And it just keeps coming out more and more that he gets busted with all this
bullshit more and more.
They just did a story on him in her own and was saying that he comes from a
suburbian area,
you know,
he's not even from the hood.
So,
uh,
I mean,
you know,
just,
it just doesn't end with this guy.
And he's making records you though,
you know?
Yeah.
He's the first major artists they ever had.
The council was a concert from death threats.
You know what's really fucked up though?
I think he could've done everything he did with a different name.
I really
do.
I really do really hard work and some hard work.
Did some hard work.
It's not like you didn't do any hard work at all.
He definitely put out those albums.
He definitely does those shows.
He's definitely hustling,
right?
Yeah.
So why the fuck did he have to try to do it under your name?
It's like he showed just as grand weakness as a man,
you know,
who are you?
You know,
it's one thing if you invent your name,
like you want to be Jay z,
you know?
Or even Jz.
Supposedly there was a dude named jazz.
Oh,
oh.
That was in his community.
That was like an older rapper that was really bad ass.
So he showed her like,
Damn Cherokee jet magazine.
You're doing it.
How do you know?
I know shit.
I got my thumb on the pulse of a part of the hood.
You know Joe connected,
man Joe is connected.
I try to pay attention to shit,
dude.
But I mean,
it's one thing to,
to make your own name,
you know,
to call yourself 50 cent or whatever.
But if you get him take another man's name,
you're dealing with a completely different thing.
Like that's not,
you didn't make up a name,
you're a crazy person.
Well,
you know,
the whole thing about being successful,
I mean,
I mean the way when I came up,
the whole thing about being for sec successful was to be able to do it yourself.
Right?
You know not to where you come and you know somebody just come and they bless
you with everything that you need and,
and here you are.
You know you're successful now,
but you didn't earn it.
You don't know how you did it.
Right when I started,
I wanted to make a name for myself and I felt that what he's doing right now,
he's making a name for me,
not for himself.
He's helping you trust me with everybody else's hell people.
This is all helping you.
I guarantee you it's way better than that.
This guy wasn't around,
this guy wasn't around.
You got to jail.
It's like,
well,
you know,
sort of life as usual and people are gonna want to listen to your story.
But now the story becomes Uber crazy.
Yeah.
It becomes really sure.
Cause it's not like,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of dudes like gangster rappers especially,
they'll,
they'll sort of have like a tribute name,
like the call himself,
something Gambino or,
you know what I mean?
But they won't use the whole name,
you know,
they won't say,
I'm Al Capone.
Like,
come on.
You can't say,
you know,
when you say you're Rick Ross,
he did that.
I think thinking you would never come out of jail.
Yeah.
I don't think that they thought I would ever get out.
Um,
in,
you know,
it was vacant.
They felt it was a vacant house.
Why the House move in?
Yeah.
Because it was really like a squatter.
You know,
he was the squatters and he squatted on my name and it's all your,
your reality happened before the Internet.
You're,
you're the,
the craziness of your,
you know,
you're selling drugs.
You're basically being one of the biggest drug dealers the country has ever
known.
Like all that happened,
pre-internet,
it happened today.
He would never be able to use that name.
Oh,
no,
absolutely.
Yeah.
But you know,
I mean,
it is what it is.
Joe [inaudible]
Fascinating Hee Hee Hee Hee Hee,
Hee Hee
got it.
You know what I'm saying?
And,
and now he has a name and,
and what I want right now is just for to stop using it
and then pay me a little my dividends that,
you know,
what I made from using my name.
I'll tell you this,
kickback in,
he's never gonna stop using it and he's not that hard.
Why won't it tattooed where he can get us,
they remove tats.
But once it's added to a man's name on your fucking hands,
you got me and you gotta fight.
You gotta fight it.
He was in love with you for sure.
That has gotta be crazy.
Every time he,
Jack's office sees your name on it,
that's crazy.
He's brushing his teeth.
He sees your name on his hands and he knows how you feel about it too.
You know,
it's,
it's not like,
you know,
you're like some dude who's like living to bet and you know,
hiding in a village.
She doesn't have to have contact with,
you know,
I'm out there,
grinding.
I believe.
Truly believe it's a gift.
I really do.
I think the whole thing is a gift.
He's a ridiculous human being.
God,
everything you told me to do,
so boy,
you was right about it.
I'm,
I'm an idiot.
Savant man.
Trust me on this.
The,
I think that he's him being so ridiculous.
He's a preposterous human being.
He's obese.
He's covered in tattoos.
He's a fake rapper.
Who was at one point in time,
a corrections officer for that guy to take your name.
It's glorious.
Yeah.
It's like you couldn't,
if anybody couldn't ask for anything better,
I couldn't ask for a better candidate because when they investigated they go
check this one of the fun.
Right.
And here's what's even better.
He's actually talented.
So a lot of people are going to hear about them.
Yeah.
So a lot of people are going to hear his name.
A lot of people going to hear the story.
So He's a gift to you.
He really is.
This guy is the greatest PR representative you could have ever hired by far.
No one could ever reach as many people and somehow under the give the seeds of
your story as this guy pretending to be.
You know what?
I got a guy.
He wants to meet you.
Yeah.
He may be able to reach more guys in and then that guy,
he's,
he's uh,
he's the world's greatest spammer.
The world's greatest spammer.
Yeah.
His name is Bill Wagner.
I don't think I would want to be in the room with that dude.
What we get in a fight with them that was fuck,
I'm the shit.
No bill to get your email.
And he said did,
he does,
he does have like a little following.
He doesn't know who they are.
Right.
But he says every time he goes on to show if somebody calls in and bad mouth
him,
what are these guys going again?
So really instead of like a thousand pizzas.
Okay,
that's fine.
But there'll be a wants to meet you,
man.
Okay,
well we'll hook it up.
They have this,
this guy though.
What?
I'm going back to the,
the fake Rick Ross,
his him as a publicist,
like if you hired him to get your name in Korea,
fortunate,
you know,
how much money it would cost to just to get as much attention as it's got.
The fact that he stole your name and the fact that so many people were talking
about it.
I mean that's an incredible story that like I would have to think,
well,
I didn't look at it and I didn't look at it like that.
Millions of people have heard that story now.
You know how I'm more to the point to where you know,
the guy stole my name.
He didn't have the decency to come and say,
look man,
I bought your name.
I'm going to give it back.
I'm just trying to change the whole way you look at it because I really believe
the universe gave you a gift.
You're looking at it like this dude came along and he victimize you and he
fucked you over and he owes you.
And I see that too.
But I say,
the universe owes you a gift,
a gave you a gift.
And that gift is you've got an idiot,
you got a silly person pretending to be you who's super talented.
I mean the guy's really that every day I'm hustling.
That's a bad ass song.
That's about our song.
Even if he stole your,
like the way you talk about shit and like you said that that was like your quote
everyday I'm hustling,
right?
Yeah.
I couldn't put it in a song.
Anyway,
he,
the guy did a great job with it.
What I'm saying is that,
and so so many people will pay attention to him because how good he is now.
He's a fucking talented God and then on top of that he's got your name tattooed
on his hands and then it just spills out from there.
It's a beautiful,
he's like,
it's like a Trojan horse.
Like he,
he'll get your story into neighborhoods where it would never ordinarily be.
If people investigate them,
all they have to do is Google the real Rick Ross.
Boom.
The story pops up within the first two or three paragraphs and everybody's going
to go,
what?
It becomes crazy.
Yeah.
I think it's a gift.
I mean a,
uh,
when you look at it from that aspect,
um,
I mean,
I guess you're right.
You can't lose,
you're not losing,
he can't stop you from using your name.
Not your real name is fucking Rick Ross.
He can't say shit,
but has a lot of
who's that,
you know,
like say for is I want to go to universal and get a record deal and it's not
going to happen.
Yeah.
That would be interesting
if I want to go to Warner brothers and get a record deal because he's already
working with them.
Yeah.
What would they do if you,
what if you were just undeniable and you had a gigantic following you the
baddest fucking rapper on earth,
but your name was also Rick Ross.
What the fuck would they do?
Well,
they do,
you gotta change your name now,
but you need a stage name.
Rick Ross.
He can't be Rick [inaudible] Roberts.
William Roberts is the actual fake Rick Ross's name.
That's what you should do to change my name and when you were out and see if I
can make that,
make that a Jack Daniels.
Roberts is kind of a bad ass ne.
There's nothing wrong with William Roberts.
His Dad thought it was pretty good.
Yeah,
it's a good name.
That's a strong name.
You Know William Roberts.
That's it.
There's nothing wrong with that name.
You know,
it's not,
look,
Henry Winkler lived his whole life as Henry Winkler.
He turned out great.
Henry Winkler can't fuck with that.
William Hogg William Gangster too.
It does.
Sounds like a dude holding a glass of Cognac with a pistol.
And I'm saying Jack Daniels.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm fascinated by the most ridiculous aspects of our culture.
One of the most ridiculous aspects of our culture of fakers.
You know,
people like,
you know,
whether it's a guy who pretends that he was a
navy seal who wasn't and he gets caught.
I love reading that Shit,
man.
There was a dude that was on this,
uh,
mixed martial arts forum.
He was like one of the oldest guys to ever fight in an MMA fight.
He fight an MMA fight when he was like 60 guy was crazy big yoked up dude at 62
but apparently it was a big crazy liar too.
And he like pretended to be like in the,
in the special forces and pretended to like have a bunch of kills in Vietnam.
And meanwhile he like worked behind a desk somewhere.
Like they found it was a total liar,
just made up the store.
But he had a whole security company and everything.
I am fascinated by that shit.
I'm fascinated.
I can't,
I,
when I find fakers fakers to me,
are there the perplexing,
well,
I think we breeding a whole culture now fakers I mean,
when you watch TV with the reality shows,
it's just so much,
and I think that could be bad for us,
for our kids,
you know,
for our kids to get that dead,
dead,
dead ideas that,
you know,
you can fake it and be successful and really not be successful.
I mean,
it's kind of,
I don't know.
Yeah.
We've,
we've given a whole generation of people the idea that you can become famous for
having no qualities.
Yeah,
exactly.
Nothing.
There's nothing there other than,
you know,
some people want to fuck you.
I guess he didn't like you.
Why you watch one of those Kim Kardashians chosen you.
You will shut that TV off and just stare at the wall for an hour going,
what the fuck is going on here?
What did I just watch?
I just watched a dumb girl go shopping.
I mean this is the craziest shit ever that they made a TV show out of it.
Yeah,
they got some of the craziest stuff on TV now and then and,
and most of it's about faking.
Know the basketball wives.
I think that's going to be a backlash though.
I think one of the things we're dealing with is,
first of all,
the fact that TV has really only been around for a couple generations.
You know,
the,
the television,
the reality of it.
When did it start in the 50s that's not enough time for us to really get a
handle of what the fuck it's doing to our culture and then do something about
it.
And whenever there's any sort of a,
an opportunity to be opportunistic to make some cash.
The easiest way to make some cash,
it's just put some stupid people on TV and make them do ridiculous shit that
people go,
what the fuck are they doing?
But you're watching dummy and then they sell you tide in the commercials and
you,
you know,
we didn't want to make some money though.
You don't want smart people on TV.
I don't believe that.
I really think that it's just,
it's not,
it's not that they don't want smart people on TV.
It's just that they want a lot of people to watch and it's lazy.
But the easy way to get a lot of people to watch,
it's just put ridiculous shit on like Jersey Shore.
Like you know,
just real housewives where you know,
these bitches are going to scream and yell at each other over nothing.
And they talk about nonsense.
They're minds are filled with air.
There's no nothing going on other than she said this and I said this and I was
like,
fuck you bitch.
You don't even fucking know me.
Don't fuck with me.
What are you watching?
You're watching more on squawk.
You're not even watching a language.
You watching birds going.
That's what you're watching.
You watching the human equivalent to crows,
the nonsense people.
But you can make money off them and you put them on TV if you're lazy.
But did the people that are producing those shows,
is that their true interest?
You don't know.
I mean there's,
in some ways it's kind of fun cause it's like the fast food of,
of television.
You know,
if you're sitting there eating lunch,
she turned on the TV real quick and you watch two bitches yell at each other,
you fucking,
who am I?
Tits are real.
You know,
he watched that shit.
It'll,
you'll laugh,
you'll you,
you goof at it.
But the problem is that it becomes a major part of our programming when it,
you know,
it's x amount of percentage of all that's on television.
Absolutely.
In any,
it affects us in ways that so many people don't really understand.
I mean,
even like with myself,
when I look back at my life,
I know that television movies affected how I made my decisions because that
became my reality.
You know?
And when you're young and you're impressionable,
then you see something and you say,
Oh man,
that shit is real.
Yeah,
I'm gonna try that myself and see if it works for me.
You know,
just like with this Guy William Roberts,
a new rapid is using my name Rick Ross.
Uh,
I believe that he's given kids the wrong impression that you can go out and sell
drugs and parlay that into a a record career.
And I believe this is going to have a tremendous backlash on our young,
on our young people.
That's also an issue with you.
You,
this guy using your name and it's not a guy like Jay z to choose your name,
who's a,
you know,
an excellent member of the community.
A guy who's a real good business man,
a guy who was very smart.
It doesn't say stupid shit.
And his raps,
your fiance.
That was Beyonce.
That's all I care.
Yeah,
I mean you're,
you're looking at a guy who's a preposterous person and so,
you know,
his,
his whole persona is sort of really the polar opposite of everything that you
have been speaking about since you got out.
What I learned,
I mean,
you know,
I learned now that I was duped and then I was bamboozled into believing that did
I was one thing in and I could have been anything.
You know,
if somebody would've came to me like you did [inaudible] and gave me the t shirt
game,
then I would have been selling tee shirts.
So I believe that what he's doing is basically what he's doing is,
is lacing the kids' boots just like you did with me,
but he's lacing them for negativity
and it's a bullshit story.
His story is a bullshit story and it doesn't work as a fairy tale.
It's a fairy tale.
So I think that,
um,
your story is also a very important story for people to,
uh,
to listen to when there's a lot of folks that have that sort of nonsense.
You got to pull yourself up by your bootstraps mentality when it comes to
certain aspects of our society,
especially people that grow up in a impoverished areas,
people that grow up in the ghetto,
there's this sort of,
well you got to fucking make it out on your own sort of mentality.
I think that's a crazy way to look at raising children.
I do too.
I think it's insane.
I think this does not,
there's only one way to raise children correctly.
Love and someone who they can respect and someone who provides a good example,
someone who they can learn from.
And if a kid is not around that there,
it's,
it's a free for all.
Absolutely.
And you don't know where he's gonna land.
Right?
And they're being raised essentially by a bunch of people that grew up in the
same exact environment.
So there's no breaking that cycle.
It's a cycle.
And I think that's one of the biggest problems in our entire society.
And I think that we spent all this time looking at things that can weaken
America overseas when the number one most important commodity in,
in,
in our,
our culture is us itself,
human beings.
The more we w all,
everything that's been built,
every pit thing that's been invented,
everything that's been engineered,
everything that's on this earth that makes our life better is made by a human.
That means a human invented that that means all this potential that's in these
impoverished communities.
It gets ignored.
All this potential we'll have of discovery,
of curiosity,
of of creativity.
All of it gets wasted in a world of crime and and repeating cycles and that as a
resource and no one looks at no one,
no one in this country looks at that.
We look at,
Oh,
we need oil.
We got to go over here.
We looked at this.
Our number one resource is human beings are the bay.
I mean,
and when you look at resources like what is important to us as humans,
other humans,
man,
other humans have it set up so we don't have to go hunt some food.
We can go to the store and buy a steak.
You know,
you don't even have to cook it.
You go right next door,
there's places bad ass,
they'll,
they'll cook it for you.
They know what to do,
they know the right seasonings.
And he's like,
we've,
we've simplified the whole game of being a human being because we're important
because so many of us get together and we provide the resources for each other
and we have a system and it all works out well.
Well you got to got to look at it in terms of where,
where does that all come from?
It all comes from children.
It all comes from,
that's when you really have your shot.
You really have your shot when you growing and developing and learning things.
And so your,
your story is a really,
really important story to be told because your finding yourself in a situation
where you couldn't read and you're already out of high school and you,
you find yourself all of a sudden involved in this drug d game.
And that seems like the only prospect say you couldn't go to school for,
for,
for uh,
for tennis because he did not read.
You made it through school system without knowing how to read.
And that's common that that happens a lot,
a lot more than people want to admit.
65% of the guys in prison can't read.
That's fucking crazy.
That is fucking crazy.
You know the,
someone posted something,
cause I'm always talking about this,
about how many,
uh,
different prisons are privatized in this country and how many are actually
privately owned institutions.
That's,
that's the big business right now.
There's,
it's,
it's somewhere around eight to 10% depending on who you ask of all the prisons
in this country.
And it's switched.
When I was in prison,
they were trying out even the prisons that was owned by the federal government.
We're starting to turn the prisons over to,
uh,
to wagon hood,
Jesus Christ.
It's really crazy.
The idea that you could put people in jail and you can make money from it,
and that there's actually like a whole crop of people,
they're going to come out of this one area.
As long as the ignore it.
Well,
we're not a,
they said that they can tell from a kid that's in the third grade,
if he's going to prison and that was a psychologist or this,
that's what they say and yeah,
that's ridiculous that you can't tell her that you could pull that kid out of
there and straighten them out.
I mean,
almost any kid can be raised correctly.
It's just almost every kid can be fucked up if they're not raising.
Absolutely.
I don't think that it did.
It did.
It matters that really the kid,
it's,
it's really the environment,
you know,
if you leave a kid in an environment where there's crime,
uh,
they'll start to adopt to the crime.
You know,
I think the crime is okay and it's,
I mean,
because I had got to the point where I believe that that was the way of life.
You know,
that's how everybody did it.
Yeah.
I think that's the environment that you grow up in is a huge factor on who you
become.
It's a huge,
huge factor and like I said,
the one of the weakest areas of our country or the places with the most crime
and the places with the most despair,
and that's the places that also get the least attention.
It's like it's like we are,
we are a person that has like a pile of garbage in the corner of the house and
we keep saying we're going to get to it,
but we just ignore it and walk around it instead of just fixing it.
I said it gives us fixing the situation.
If we put just a 10th of what we put into our military budget,
just one 10th to just settle the,
the inner cities down,
provide guidance,
put,
put places in where people can stay if they have nowhere to go and just educate
people better.
Just make it so there's profit in rebuilding cities the same way.
There's profit and rebuilding cities the way we bomb the fuck out of him.
If we could just figure out how to do that.
Was He me and you need to go up in Whitehouse and help Obama out.
Uh,
because I say it takes some of that money.
They spend it on the drug war.
You know,
they spend like $60 billion a year fighting,
fighting drug.
Yeah.
You know what the problem with stopping the drug warriors,
there's a whole lot of people fighting the drug war and they'll be out of work.
That's going to be a real problem.
One of the things that keeps drugs,
certain drugs illegal as they,
the,
you know,
the prison guards actually have lobbyists.
They want to make sure that certain drug laws are there.
They stay in place because that keeps them in business.
Absolutely.
Which is career easy that someone would actually,
without having to be there and see the look in a person's eyes when they slammed
this,
the sell on them,
when I'll actually be there and experience their pain,
they're willing to make that decision because they're so far removed from it.
It's just them,
you know,
talking to a lobbyist and you know,
writing something down and they,
they sign something and make an agreement,
shake some hands,
and then all of a sudden,
boom,
this cell somewhere down the line gets shot on a man and a man loses his life.
He loses the,
the reality of the life that he lived because someone is making some money off
of him being in jail.
The children lose a fallacy.
Yeah.
Children lose a father.
The wife loses of Yasmin and crazy and for victimless crimes and for some it
means something completely illogical.
Like most drugs,
when you look at most drugs,
the harm that most drugs do,
this is nothing compared to the harm that legal shit like alcohol does,
which nobody's trying to stop.
I never heard a single politician say we need to stop people smoking cigarettes.
I've never heard one.
I'm just waiting for one person to stand up and say,
do you know that there is a company that is selling poison that kills half a
million people every year,
every year in this country,
half a million people died because of that.
This company that's selling poison that they know kills people and they're
making billions of dollars.
Well you know what,
he's going to lose his contribution.
He so he can't say,
yeah,
they can't say it.
They never will say it.
But I mean,
if a new company that came along that was just selling poison to kids,
would it really be as bad as cigarettes?
I mean,
I don't want to compare cigarettes to math because math does a quicker job.
I mean I'm,
I don't want to exaggerate the effect,
but when you see a dude is like 70 years old,
been smoking cigarettes this whole life,
he's doing this
and then he takes another drag and you go,
Whoa,
they got that dude.
Yeah.
And they got him and trying to get new ones cause they always kill the
customers.
Yeah.
I mean,
but,
but they keep you around.
They slow cook you,
you know,
they're like a smoker.
It's,
it's only 150 degrees.
You've got to take a day to cook you,
it takes a long time to kill you with cigarettes.
It's not a quick thing.
To me.
It's,
it's a,
it's amazing that no one ever brings it up.
It never even gets talked about.
Well,
somebody like you and you know that we need people that's going to stand up and
in and educate our people.
Man,
I have too many soft skeletons in my closet.
They need someone that listens to me that's got the fucking feed on the straight
and narrow.
Hey,
I mean,
nobody's perfect.
We all got,
we all got our phones.
Oh,
I know.
We all have.
But you know,
that's my path is definitely not to be in any form of political office.
It's not a,
it's not for me.
I don't have that time.
I don't want to like listen to anybody and I don't,
I don't want to have to do shit I don't want to do.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't want that responsibility.
This system too.
I feel like jumping into this system,
it's like it just jumping into a tank full of sharks.
It's like you don't know the rules.
You know how these fucking crazy assholes been operating.
I would like to talk to Arnold.
I would like to see.
Ask him what the fuck was it like to go from being Mr Olympia?
Do me and the governor of California.
You don't think he'd come here and sit down with you?
He might.
I bet I could get them maybe in a year,
like maybe not right now.
I'm starting to get bigger examples.
I'd have to find someone.
I actually do something.
Know someone who knows him.
Bryan Callen did a movie with him.
He said he was great.
He's a great guy.
But he was hilarious.
Fun.
And this is like after the scandal with is made everyday
you so do you know how many men get to have two wives?
He's living in the same house.
Damn
the Arnold.
He's quite a character.
I would like to talk to him about what it was like to be a governor.
Whether it was what he thought it was going to be like.
Cause you look at that shit from the outside,
you know,
what is it?
What the hell do you do once you get in there?
Yeah.
How could you fix any of this stuff?
I'm looking at her like we don't have any money.
Like God damn like the money for schools and money for all these programs that
you wanting in this ga,
the there's,
there's,
there's really not that much resources.
It's gotta be really difficult and then you've got all these people that try to
steal all of these people were trying to get,
oh no I'm trying to steal.
They trying to steal from each other.
You know you got to hide the money from him.
I would love to get high with Obama
if I had like one thing,
if you said,
would you like to be able to fly
like through the air like superman for three hours,
fly wherever you want or sit down smoke weed with Obama for three hours.
I will take the ladder.
I would smoke with what Obama more than I would fly like superman for three
hours.
And that's saying a lot because flying like superman would be cool as fuck if
you could do that.
Especially if you were high and you flew like superman flying super formal would
be better flying a super woman would be backed up.
Cause you have boobs and a vagina up.
You always say this,
it's not true.
It's way better to check and then you start crying hour.
Get your period halfway in the middle of their flight.
Stop.
I would,
every time I would love to talk,
shut up.
I would love to talk to that dude and find out what it's like to actually be the
presence.
Yeah.
At night we'll talk to him to tell him,
my guys,
my homeboys in prison for non violent offenses.
When you're going to let him out,
do you think he would do it?
Do you think he would ever sit down with someone like you and have a
conversation?
He might be,
yeah.
The only guy that's,
every map isn't a medical correct.
It's an hour with me,
you know,
but he's what you call his name
duck.
It's like he can't,
he can't win again.
Can you imagine the headlines?
President Obama sits down with drug dealer.
Yeah.
But you know,
you've shown since you've got out the,
you've been trying to put people on a path different than the one that you've
been on.
I think that's all you can ask for a man.
He can't ask for a man to not make mistakes.
We asked for a man is to,
once he's made mistakes,
be honest about those mistakes and try to help people to keep them from making
the same mistakes themselves.
You've done that.
That's an example.
Lee.
They still,
you know,
want to throw the drug dealer,
the drug B,
just listen.
They don't appreciate that you were a bad motherfucker in an illegal business.
Okay.
That's what it is.
The they'd done or appreciate that bad motherfuckers in illegal business are
still bad motherfuckers.
You know,
you just,
you,
you focused your energies
and I didn't put a gun to nobody's here.
You know,
I've never,
I never walked up to nobody and say,
look,
what the fuck are you going to smoke this here?
Right.
Get the pipe,
picked the pipe up it on here and smoke it right now.
Why do you think you would have been able to,
I mean,
it's really kind of,
I hate to say this again,
but it really kind of is a gift that you got stopped from,
from,
you know,
from continuing to sell drugs because there's no old drug dealers,
there's no bold drug dealers and there's no old drug dealers.
No.
And there's certainly no old bold drug dealers.
Right?
You get to a certain point in time if somebody wants your spot or some,
there's something going on or there's a lot of money involved,
shit goes down.
But you managed to avoid all of that.
And I did 20 years though.
You did.
And you learn how to write.
Okay.
And when you came out,
look at you now,
look at you now.
You're,
you're positive.
You're happy.
Every time I see you're smiling,
you have a warm way about you.
You're,
you know,
you're very personable with people.
Like I would never wish 20 years in prison on anybody,
but you handled it about as good as a person can do.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
when I was there,
I made up my mind that I wasn't gonna let prison do me.
Right.
You know,
a lot of guys when they come there,
they mope around and they cry about being here.
And what I said is that,
you know what,
I'm gonna make the best of this because I'm going home.
Even though I had a life sentence,
I always had in the back of my mind that,
that I was going to get out one day.
And so I started preparing to do that because I knew nobody was going to hire
me.
You know,
some told me say,
man,
if you ever get out,
the first thing they going to say about you is you're a drug dealer.
So you got to do something to where you can
get in and you don't have to need anybody to approve you.
You know,
like so many guys,
they get out,
they have to go to people,
you know,
go to Mcdonald's,
fill out an application and hoping that they accept them.
Well,
I don't work like that,
right?
I work two away when nobody has the approved me but myself.
Well that's what you,
the way you would like to work.
Yeah.
Everybody,
everybody would like to be in that situation.
But you demand that and that's what made you a bad motherfucker and an illegal
business.
And that's what makes you a bad motherfucker and legal businesses that you focus
yourself on.
Yeah.
It's,
it's really,
um,
it's,
I think like for someone like a Obama or anyone to meet with you,
I think it's,
it's important to give people the,
the,
the first of all to show people your story and second of all,
to let people know that when you make mistakes in life and you can correct those
and be better because of it and then have,
part of your contribution is explaining and mistakes and letting them,
and I think that's important.
It's very important.
I think it's very important that the people who've made mistakes come back and
tell others,
well,
you know what?
If you go that way,
this is what's going to happen.
But a lot of people,
you know,
they,
they don't look at it that way.
You know,
like sometimes I want to go out and speak to kids and they,
uh,
one day I'm at a US high school in La and,
they call the news and tell them,
hey,
they got a drug dealer on the campus and saw the news crew.
They shoot down to the school and,
and just as I'm walking out and they like,
uh,
where's the drug do they says a drug dealer on?
And I said,
no,
I was an ex drug dealer.
And uh,
they said,
oh no,
we thought it was somebody else.
So,
you know,
sensationalism.
They're just looking for,
for things to be excited.
When,
you know,
negative news sales,
they're not looking for anything positive.
They don't want to portray a positiveness in,
in,
in what I'm doing.
And you know,
and I can deal with that because I'm not doing it for their approval.
I'm doing it because this is what I liked doing and,
and I think it's the right thing for me to do.
I think it's the right thing for you to,
to,
and I think that what you said about that it's good for people to see these
examples of people who've made mistakes and explained their mistakes.
I think it's something that's missing in our world,
you know?
And I think that if there were more books written instead of just about crime
and glorifying crime,
how about written about dudes who did shit and wish they could take it back?
You know?
How about talk to dudes who murdered their wife and like,
God damn it,
I love that girl.
Like what the fuck was wrong with me?
Well,
once you settled down and you realize how crazy were you when he killed someone
and then there's no,
there's very few books where people are honest about that,
about,
oh,
we'll let someone else guys in prisons,
you know,
I think that we should have a system where guys and an in prison in these
maximum security prison get away to tell the kids,
what is it like,
you know,
sitting in a cell by yourself 23 hours a day or 24 hours a day.
Well,
I know they had that scared straight.
You know,
they had that a scared straight program that they were doing kids for a while.
They all made a lot of videos about that.
Do you remember that?
I remember that when I was growing up.
Uh,
I mean something even more because I don't,
I don't know if that was real or not seem a little theatrical.
Right.
Yeah.
I'm talking about something that it's really cause a lot of those guys in
prison,
you know,
even like the Guy Larry Hoover,
who,
uh,
who the rapper rapped about,
I think a guy like him,
he's famous and he would be great to reach out to the kids and tell the kids
what it's like to live in the maximum,
you know,
one of the most secure printers,
penitentiaries in the United States.
I mean,
cause I'm even fascinated with what it's like in there.
You know,
I hear that they're,
they're locked down 23 hours a day.
Uh,
the shower moves to their door.
So,
you know,
you don't come out your cell,
the shower,
um,
your mail comes over a screen.
I mean,
it's like terrible.
You don't have any human contact.
Wow.
So everyone's essentially in solitary.
Yup.
And then one hour a day you are you,
are you allowed to mingle with people?
Well,
you're allowed to go out in the sun.
And is there other people out there as well?
I don't think so.
So you go out in the sun by herself,
right in a little box.
I think they use a little box,
you know,
where,
Oh my God,
the sun can shine down probably through a window or something.
You know,
they let you play handball or,
or something like that.
Oh my God,
what a,
I hear this awful thing,
you know?
And,
and we got guys there that,
that should be able to tell the stories.
Yeah.
That's a crazy life.
That's um,
the world changing,
not the way I had planned on living life and,
and you know,
I was close to it to living like that.
You know,
I,
I missed that by really just a few decisions.
You know,
I made a few of the right decisions at the right time and,
and,
and it's bad me from being in that position because I could have made some
decisions that could have landed media.
You know,
it was times that other people were suggesting doing is here,
dude is here something violent,
something violent,
you know,
somebody had run off with some money and you know,
my guys and man let's teach them a lesson,
you know,
and it's something just,
just told me,
Nah,
that ain't the way to go.
Well the is very intelligent and that you did that.
It's um,
I think it's a,
your story,
like I said,
it's very important for young people.
I remember very clearly how stupid I was when I was 13 or 14 or I would think
about the future and where it would be.
And I really remember like,
I could've made a million dumb decisions when I was that age.
And I think every time you as a young man get to see the example of people
who've made mistakes and correct them or you know,
went the wrong way in life.
And then re re wrote their path later in life and became successful.
I think those are the really important for,
for young people to shape their vision of the world.
To understand that there's going to be decisions that you're going to have to
make and part of the learning process is making the wrong decision.
Absolutely.
Well,
you know,
a one time I read a book about a guy in a,
he was saying that people think that he's smart and he said that he don't think
he's smart.
He just made a lot of bad decisions.
And by making so many bad decisions,
he made a few correct ones.
Yeah.
That,
that is a weird thing where we want people to have never made any bad decisions.
We want you to only be correct all the time.
Yeah.
And,
and you have to develop,
you know,
one of the things that,
that,
um,
that I've been telling the young people I'm working with right now.
You know,
I've got a young artist that I'm,
that I'm working with right now.
See Carter shout out to see Carter.
Y'All check out at AMC on
you're managing or managing it.
Managing.
See Dope to see Carter is sealed,
like let her see.
Yeah,
and then another c.
Yup.
See Carter.
And when the main things that I'm trying to get her to understand and she got it
she's had,
she has a remarkable story too,
when people investigate it and find out what she comes from,
and she was telling me she's never had anybody like me to give her the advice
that I'm giving it.
And one of the things that I tell her is that you must continue to develop in
order to develop,
you have to try new things and when you try new things,
you're going to make some mistakes.
Long as you don't make mistakes,
it's going to send you to prison or kill you.
You good?
Yeah.
As long as you make the mistakes that you're just taking chances,
you're not doing something fucked up.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's a lot of mistakes that are most important things that you're ever going
to do in your life.
Some of the failures that I've had over years,
I've been like the motivating factors for success times a million.
Like if I had done well instead of just failed miserably,
maybe I wouldn't have gotten so excited about picking up the pieces and get my
shit together again.
You know?
I think that some of the biggest fuck ups I've ever had are like the most
motivating factors in my life.
Yeah.
You know,
I think people need to hear that ma'am.
Well,
definitely for mine.
You know,
one of the biggest mistakes I made was to get involved with selling cocaine,
you know,
but it's been one of the,
probably the most educational things in my whole life.
You know,
I spent in the whole game,
I spent about 28 years,
you know,
selling it for eight and then the 20 years I did in prison.
So it was a big chunk of my life that I spent in that game.
But I learned so much from that,
that a man I couldn't,
I wouldn't give it back for nothing.
It's a fascinating thing,
isn't it?
It's just the life that you think you're going to live when you were a kid,
watching TV shows and then the actual life that you've lived at for all these
years.
Yeah.
It gets very strange,
doesn't it?
It does.
It
the [inaudible]
now you,
I know you're in the middle of some sort of a court case with this dude who's
stealing your name.
What,
where does it stand right now?
Oh,
we have a trial date right now,
uh,
against one of brothers.
We go to trial August of 27.
MMM.
Just come from court for that right now.
Can't talk about it.
Right.
Uh,
but
you know,
I,
I'm not going to give up,
you know,
no matter what they do and you know,
they throw all these lorries at me,
you know,
have they tried to give you like a settlement or has anybody tried to,
would you ever license your name if you want?
Like,
like,
Hey,
I get 30% of everything.
Yeah.
I don't want to,
you know,
uh,
but at the same time,
you know,
I'm really
okay.
Tired of dealing with,
with this issue,
you know,
maybe you could license it openly on the Internet and a lot of people can become
Red Cross.
Oh yeah.
That would make it a website you want Rick Ross the Internet with Rick Ross is
if you do like as a paypal thing where it's only five bucks and for five bucks
you could use the name Rick Ross.
So all these people's websites,
so like the newest of the new Rick Ross and obvious like white dudes with red
hair pretending to be the newest Rick Ross because they licensed that for five
bucks and then that should becomes a joke and then he becomes a ridiculous
person.
Ridiculous.
And he'd probably make a lot of fucking money.
And by the way,
the other people,
how long are they going to keep using that name?
Oh,
like a week.
They're going to just,
it's gonna fuck around,
you know,
adopted forever.
A lot of people would and tattoo it on them.
At least one dude,
at least one new we tattooed on him.
Did you see that crazy girl who met a dude for 24 hours?
And then had him tattoo his name on her face.
Yes.
That was the most horrific thing I've ever seen in my life,
and let me find the picture of the picture when he can.
It's unbelievable.
I guess it was in Russia or something like that.
Her whole face was this dude's like her out the whole side of her face.
He tattooed in giant black letters.
His name.
Wow.
Yeah.
Whoa.
I might try it.
Find out a thing though.
That sounded like a,
yeah,
it's not a bad idea.
You can be warm.
You can won't cost me anything.
Licensed.
The name Rick Ross it across your $5.
The only problem with that is then it sets a precedent and then the the the Rick
Ross,
Robert Goes,
well,
I'll give you five bucks.
Shit,
look at this.
Look at this,
this horrific tattoo.
This girl got on the left and the right side of her face.
It's unbelievable.
It's like a car.
This guy just tattooed his name across her face.
This photo,
it looks like she was a pretty girl.
Oh,
she was beautiful.
They had a picture of her before the Tattoo.
It's crazy.
I mean,
what was she thinking about?
I don't know.
She's nuts.
Look at the guy.
He's got tattoos all over his face.
Oh,
she was really pretty before that.
Scroll back up again.
This guy is letting her do this dude.
He did it to her.
He tattooed her.
What a jerk.
He's not a nice guy.
It makes me mad.
World's fucked man.
There's at least one dual tattoo.
Your name on their knuckles.
We've been,
we've been not try that.
Yeah,
let's not try that until after the settlement.
After the settlement.
After Rick,
inevitably he's going to have to pay you.
There's inevitably going to have to pay you,
but when he pays you,
what does he do?
Does it become Rosie?
Does he change his name and just become Roseanne?
That's his new,
he sort of got like a escape identity,
right?
He sort of got a bit of an escape identity with that other name,
Yeah.
He came up with that to offset.
It's not a bad move.
He should really commit to that.
I think he should commit to it,
to his real name.
When you're proud of it.
Yeah.
That's still around.
You didn't come to a concert.
That's my son up there and if he's built like his dad,
his dad probably had around,
I would change my name to r two R Two d two r two R to recross to just arterial.
Yes.
That's Kinda hip are our dose.
The whole thing's a mess,
man.
Um,
is it surreal to you?
I mean,
how does it feel like to,
to have a guy that you see on the cover of Rolling Stone magazine,
you see your name on it and you just like,
what is the,
what can you live in?
Then it kind of lets me know that I did accomplish something in life.
Right?
I mean,
you know when,
when people start naming themselves after you,
you know,
you came right,
you did it.
So it's such a fascinating way because he did it.
First of all,
you avoided violence and then you got out and then learn how to read when
through fruit,
through jail and everything.
And then you came out and then you'll like this peaceful person.
It's like you managed to avoid like a lot of the negative Karma and negative
repercussions of that situation,
but you also managed to keep that,
that name.
I mean you,
you are Rick Ross.
You're the real Rick Ross.
I heard about you before you went to jail.
I heard about you and the news.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Long time ago,
I think I was in,
we didn't know what I used to believe
when I was in the drug business.
I believed I was under the radar.
I didn't think people know about me.
Right.
Because I used to use fake names.
Yeah.
You know,
to hide myself.
when I go around people who didn't know me,
you know,
all my friends would call me,
hey Charlie.
Hey Joe.
Oh,
all the time.
Different names.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
because you don't want nobody knowing your name because if somebody knows your
name now they can tell the cops,
hey,
that guy is the guy.
That's the guy right there,
Rick Ross.
So,
you know,
we would go to clubs and stuff like that.
People would call me anything.
But Rick Ross,
you know.
Now when you found out,
when you are just,
you said you were in jail when you found out about the whole connection to the
Iran Contra scandal.
Yeah.
How did you find that out?
Well,
for the folks who don't know well,
what's happened given the,
the,
a little run down run down,
it was,
my lawyer calls me when I call my lawyer one day and we talking about my case
and he tells me,
he says,
man,
this reporter calls me and since he got some stuff for us,
but he's not going to give us what he got and this and we give me what we got
and you want to talk to him?
I'm looking at it life sentence.
So I'm like,
man,
I ain't got nothing to lose and tell him to come on down.
What are you going to do?
He can't do no more than I already done it.
So he comes down and we started talking and he's telling me about how man this
thing is bigger than you and you don't know what she was into.
And then all of a sudden I'm thinking like,
wow,
cause I just went through the thing with the crooked cops,
you know,
lac or if that was planning to drugs and stealing the money and had the houses,
in Arizona on the river and,
and whatnot.
Right.
So what I'm saying,
well maybe these might be DEA agents and this crooked,
right?
So,
uh,
I don't know.
So then all of a sudden we go to trial,
we started trial and then he doesn't give us the information,
but what he does is he started to ask questions through my lawyer and then he
starts to talk about Ronald Reagan and
Enrique Remu Tez and the Nicaraguan contras.
And I'm like the Nicaraguan contras,
what's going on this?
So I go back to my cell,
I started studying,
what was the contrast,
you know,
who is,
uh,
Enrique re mute is and,
and the whole nine yards.
He still doesn't tell me.
I don't find out the whole scoop until his newspaper drop when his newspaper
dropping the San Jose Mercury News and I'm on the front cover and it says that
the CIA backed army,
uh,
was selling drugs to me,
which they was,
I knew,
you know,
I knew blend dawn,
but I didn't know he was working with the CIA.
I mean like,
damn the guy I'm working with,
you should have told me we couldn't really,
we couldn't really got it in.
Right.
So,
uh,
that's when I first found out that was my first,
I had an in a lot of people,
you know,
they don't believe me when I tell them that I had no knowledge,
but I had absolutely no knowledge that he was a CIA operative.
It's crazy that the people that busted you were not aware of your whole
situation.
There were not aware
of who you are making money for.
No.
Well,
so that just shows you how much chaos is in that whole world of,
of black ops w you know,
drug that drug businessman.
It's,
it's,
it's so
big,
you know,
in,
and I'm not just saying from the street level,
but from,
for Dea,
you know,
uh,
I watched the documentary about two weeks ago.
I spoke at a church in Compton and they had some cops on there and we're saying
that these cops wouldn't investigate homicides because you could get a better
promotion by investigating drugs if you want to,
if you want to go and be the captain of the station,
you don't go to homicide.
If you on homicide,
you want to switch to drug enforcement because that's where they were given all
the promotions.
To tie up that story for the folks who don't know the story or listening to this
for the first time,
what he was saying was that while he was selling drugs,
hit the money that he was earning,
whether they're selling the drugs,
the drugs were actually coming from the CIA,
which was using that money to fund the Contra,
uh,
army against the Sandinistas that was backed by Reagan.
Yeah.
Reagan over and all that stuff that was on trial.
The Iran Contra trials that Oliver North United I live in north might be coming
out and speaking now real.
That's what you should get on this show.
Really speaking about what he's going to tell the truth about everything.
He's Finna come clean.
A lot of the guys
media,
he's doing a documentary and uh,
uh,
one of the producers were saying that he's interested in having me in his
documentary.
Oh my God.
So you already know it.
I'm going to tell him.
Yeah,
yeah.
You're going to be in it.
How do you not sit down and tell your story to that guy?
That's a fascinating situation.
Yeah.
So I mean that would be the last link.
So he was the guy that,
he was a big part of the organization of the whole thing,
right?
He was the guy
did that dealt with the White House,
you know,
it stopped it out of the north.
Wow.
You know,
it didn't go to Bush in,
in,
in Reagan,
out of a north stopped it at him.
I used to have an Ollie north for president t shirt.
I didn't even know the story.
I was like fucking 16 or southern.
I'd thought he was a bad motherfucker.
I mean,
you know,
he was trying to say to congeal.
Yeah.
The idea behind it though,
it was fascinating the way they chose to do it.
It's just shows you that that is the most ridiculous conspiracy theory you could
ever come up with.
The CIA's selling drugs in the ghetto and then they using that money to fund
illegal wars.
You know,
it's crazy.
How do I keep getting mixed up in these types of situations?
Right.
I got the craziest rapper in the world.
You've had an interesting life of my friend.
Take my name and then I was involved with [inaudible].
Yeah.
I mean that is one of the craziest drug stories ever.
And the fact that you got out of it completely unscathed.
I mean,
how many dudes are even still alive that you were in business with 20 years?
A lot of my friends are dead.
It must be right.
A lot of friends are dead still in
prison with life sentences.
Wow.
Um,
and,
and you know,
one of my goals is to,
to,
to change those laws and bring those guys home.
Because,
you know,
I don't think a guy should do 30 years.
He didn't kill anybody.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
100%.
[inaudible] and more so I think that we need to reevaluate what's legal and
illegal in this country because we got a,
we have a,
a corrupt series of politicians that have been bought off and I've put a bunch
of laws in place and have allowed people to sell all kinds of shit that kills
people all the time.
People voted to let them make marijuana legal and they still won't.
Yeah,
they voted to make it medically legal.
It's even the legal,
the legality of it statewide in Colorado and Washington State's coming to
question federally,
you know,
like,
I mean,
there's a bunch of gangsters run this country and they're not nice people and a
lot of the shit they're doing is stupid and it's unnecessary.
And you know,
we want a government,
we want a police force,
we want a fire department,
we want a president.
We want all that shit.
We just don't want the corruption that comes with it almost inevitably.
And it's unfortunate,
but your story is a perfect example of how fucked the whole system is.
The fact that the CIA was absolutely selling drugs,
right?
I mean,
they were selling it through you.
You're the guy.
I can't say that they wasn't actually selling it themselves.
It was their operatives that was selling it.
So these guys,
they made it very clear what this guy was in the agency.
Yeah.
He wasn't an Asian.
Well,
that's how they're making it.
He was just on our payroll.
Since the difference,
I guess you can be on the payroll.
You can get a check from the CIA,
but you're not a CIA agent.
Yeah.
It's not without,
he's not CIA.
He's just CIA.
It's a,
it's a fucked up world.
I had hoped that when Obama got in and he represented something different and
maybe he does,
maybe it's just,
it's so hard to change.
It takes a long fucking time to turn anything microphone and was fell.
Oh,
it takes a long fucking time to turn anything around,
but it's,
I want to find out,
is he going to do anything for the hood?
Well,
no,
it was the time.
Right.
He's got reelected.
Exactly.
And,
and they,
and they voted him in,
you know,
the hood came out and they don't vote.
Right.
Yeah.
Well they came out for Obama.
Twice.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
we are hoping that,
uh,
did he,
you know,
take this time and,
and,
and do something,
put some programs in the hood.
Yeah.
Like I said,
one 10th of what's used to blow up other countries could change everything
radically.
We could have a,
an incredible nation if we started focusing our resources on,
on putting money.
I mean,
it's,
we spend so much money in rehabilitating cities after we invade them.
You know,
how much money did we spend in Iraq?
How much money as a Halliburton made?
How much fun
then what they do it,
all the money.
I don't know.
Hookers,
bullets,
gasoline.
Yeah.
A lot of Shit,
man.
Listen,
I gotta wrap this up,
but uh,
thank you very much for coming by again.
And if people want to buy your shirt where,
uh,
where they buy one more time,
they can go to freeway,
social media.com freeway,
social media.com and follow the real Rick Ross on Twitter.
It's a freeway.
Ricky.
It's right.
Yeah.
Freeway.
Ricky fruit
freeway,
literacy.org yeah,
that's my nonprofit.
I got my,
No,
you have a nonprofit.
I'm taking advice,
man.
That's beautiful man.
Freeway literacy.org so that's one more time from the beginning.
It's freeway,
literacy.org freeway,
Ricky on Twitter and the other one is sweet way.
Social media.social media.com ladies and gentlemen,
go support the real Rick Ross and get yourself a fat tee shirt.
Like this one right here.
This is the real Rick Ross is not around.
It's a business that Joe got me into.
I hope you make $1 trillion off that shit.
All right.
Thank you very much everybody.
Thanks to Onnit for sponsoring this podcast.
Go to o n n I t used the code name Brogan.
Save yourself 10% off.
Brian and I,
along with Joey.
Coco Diaz will be in West Palm Beach,
Florida this weekend,
and the shit's going to be epic.
It's fun.
And Saturday night we got to fly all the way over there,
Florida.
But yeah,
any show on that,
man,
you're more than welcome.
Uh,
so Joey Diaz,
me and Brian,
couple of shows,
we're almost sold out,
so we'll be there Friday and Saturday and next week,
no podcast.
So go fuck yourself.
We'll see you soon.
We love you.
Bye.
[inaudible].